[Applause]
let us pray no I know why you're happy
today you feel safe ladies and gentlemen
we got him Bill Cosby has been found
guilty of sexually assaulting dozens of
women and he's been sentenced to 10
years in the White House so no he's easy
he's go to jail and he would best heed
the advice that he always gave younger
black men in America pull up your pants
now mister dr. Cosby there's still dr.
maybe not his lawyers are arguing for
very lenient sentencing they say because
he's completely blind no you're thinking
of the wife
now our president the president who
knows the best people not what it must
be bad luck huh because he knows the
best people another appointment went
sour dr. Ronnie Jackson you know dr.
Ronnie Jackson yes he's the physician to
the president we have one of those in
this country and it's been that way for
a long time he'd he was there for Obama
George Bush we didn't know a lot about
dr. Ronnie Jackson before but then when
Trump became president dr. roni gave him
his physical member that and said he was
in great shape and not obese at all and
we all said is this guy high drugs
so indiscriminately his nickname was the
Candyman okay hey how does this guy like
this get to be the physician to the
President and B is he still accepting
patients I'm asking for a friend
I but dr. roni said these false
allegations he's stepping down he not
gonna take the job at the VA which but
he was put up for he said these these
are allegations are false and they
become a distraction to the president a
distraction to this president all he
does is golf watch TV and eat how could
there be a distraction unless you're a
sand trap a commercial or a chicken bone
you're good
a distraction
yeah distraction
he's calling Fox and Friends and the
more did you see that did you see him
Frank call Fox and Friends yesterday oh
my god he babbled like Rain Man ate a
bag of coke
I mean the three this is where we are in
this country the three hosts a boxer
dreads looked very worried they were
like this is too stupid for us and we're
the hosts of Fox and Friends but but hey
let's not forget the good news North and
South Korea did you see this the
presidents of North and South Korea met
look at them look like the before and
after to a slim fast and super cuts
commercial hand-holding these days you
know these guys are doing it and these
two could not stop doing it the only
people we can get to do it are these two
now they've had a lot of visitors dinner
to the White House lately the Japanese
Prime Minister the French president the
German Chancellor's there now Melania
loves these state visits she now knows
how to say please take me with you in 16
languages
Malati it was her birthday this week
Trump they asked him about it on Fox in
French maybe you didn't get it too much
but then they had a little ceremony at
the White House and Trump said make a
wish and his dick fell off it's a
strange White House you have to admit
with the president and his wife have no
contact and the American President and
the French president half his age cannot
keep their hands off each other I mean
they were all over each other these two
the hugs the handshakes the two-handed
hand shakes the hand holding the cheek
kissing I thought he was gonna
I thought Trump was gonna take him
furniture shopping I mean I once went
rogue said call me by your name what
that no okay Matt okay they had the
first state dinner the Trump stood at
the White House and you know it was
France so they wanted it to be really
classy so they took the chicken out of
the bucket